hey guys this next clip was made
possible by news voice which is a
democratized news app created to fight
back against the filter bubbles caused
by corporate media download for free
from news voice calm slash Pakman or
click the link under this video
Spain has decided to cancel the sale of
weapons to Saudi Arabia because of Saudi
Arabian atrocities committed against
Yemen and this is one of those well yeah
and also too little too late stories but
it's still a correct decision I've been
talking for years on the show about the
immorality of these alliances with Saudi
Arabia including that alliance with by
the United States with Saudi Arabia the
weapons sales the oil deals the entire
thing when Saudi Arabia is one of the
most brutal oppressive religious
theocracies in the world and the shared
interest in Middle East stability has
led not just to countries looking the
other way when it comes to Saudi Arabia
when it comes to Saudi Arabia's
repression of women and the public
beheadings and everything else but it's
also led to just straight-up backward
decisions like putting saudi arabia on
the United Nations Human Rights Council
it's difficult to imagine something more
absurd than Saudi Arabia being on the
United Nations Human Rights Council but
now we have Spain which says it's going
to cancel an arms sale to Saudi Arabia
over their involvement in atrocities in
Yemen but it's not quite so simple
because there's a contract in place and
now Spain and Saudi Arabia need to get
together to negotiate around that
contract that exists because Spain wants
out but their party to a contract to
make the weapons sale to Saudi Arabia
other countries have also started to
back away a little bit from arm sales to
the United States to Saudi Arabia but
not the United States Donald Trump of
course doing a record arms deal with
Saudi Arabia six months ago maybe four
months ago reported it to you at the
time but the sad reality of this is
while I support
Spain not selling weapons to Saudi
Arabia and I would love it if the United
States said we're not going to sell
weapons anymore to Saudi Arabia every
serious analyst of the situation is
saying you know in the end Saudi
Arabia's going to get all the same
weapons the flow of weapons is going to
conceal and continue if Spain doesn't do
it some other country will make it up a
little bit could well be the United
States seems the u.s. is more willing
than ever to sell Saudi Arabia anything
that they want to buy and we've seen
Donald Trump get closer and closer and
closer to the Crown Prince of Saudi
Arabia Mohammed bin Salman and the trend
is clear the United States whether it's
a Republican or a Democrat seems
determined to continue doing business
with Saudi Arabia yes there are
differences in the approach whether it's
a Democrat or a Republican but we talk
about political issues where Democrats
and Republicans are very very different
net neutrality
many social issues LGBT rights long list
of them and then we talk about issues
where Democrats and Republicans are
basically equally you're close to
equally complicit in maintaining the
status quo that we have and part of that
relates to campaign finance part of that
relates merely to self-preservation I
got here with the system that exists do
I really want to change the system that
we have because that might push I might
push myself out of power and the Saudi
Arabia stuff yeah we hear from some
Democrats about it we hear about some
resolutions that have been proposed an
amendment here there that maybe some day
will pass by and large there has been no
serious effort at the top echelon of
power in the United States to distance
ourselves from Saudi Arabia in a serious
manner and then when it comes to Donald
Trump and his growing love affair with
Prince Mohammed bin Salman Crown Prince
Trump likes the dictatorial
authoritarian types he's impressed with
them right Trump likes Putin Trump is
impressed with air dawuan of Turkey he
likes Kim jong-un or thought he was a
great negotiator or a smart guy or a
great sense of humor and the
makes it great makes great deviled eggs
too while he's added whatever it was
Rodrigo Duterte from the Philippines
very impressed Trump was with how he was
dealing with issues of drugs the way
he's dealing with that is by saying it's
okay to just kill suspected drug dealers
and users on the street and clearly the
Saudis fall under that umbrella as well
for Donald Trump it would be great if we
had a leader that went in the total
opposite direction saying we're not
gonna sell a thing to Saudi Arabia but
unfortunately not only is that not the
direction we're going in the United
States is a bigger and bigger part of
the problem with Saudi Arabia and it
sickens me and I think that at this
point I would love to say the next step
should be pushing for a total halt
to our relationship with Saudi Arabia I
think if we could get a reduction in the
amount of weapons we sell them that
would be like a much more pragmatic
first step so to speak we are actively
making the problem worse good for Spain
for doing this even though they may be
contractually obligated to sell Saudi
Arabia some of those weapons and even if
they don't
Saudi Arabia is still gonna get them
because there are many many willing
sellers of those weapons to Saudi Arabia
around the world